immanuel Abra andis kinder mammal to
Ethiopians who set up their own business
in the heart of Addis Ababa their
company a harder tech develops programs
for mobile apps one of their main
products is designed to help Ethiopian
students is a web and mobile based
learning platform that enables students
to access learning materials using
mobile phones tablets or pcs so that
they can learn anywhere anytime is free
of charge it's financed by sponsors and
other apps that are harder Tech has
already launched a manual a bra and a
skinned imamo had the idea for the app
while studying information technology in
Germany only 40% of young Ethiopians
pursue higher education and these are
exactly the people the entrepreneurs
want to reach in studying in Germany
giving selects authority to see the
German quality of the made in Germany
the perfection if Germans are doing
something that follows mechanics has
100% quality I think Germany can learn a
lot of things for me the one thing is I
think you know flexibility you don't
have to do things just in a certain way
doing business in Addis Ababa means
having to deal with power cuts and weak
internet connections nati gasai is
working feverishly on the Fadel mobile
phone app while the computer version is
already being used by about 5,000
students the mobile app is still in
development when you open that you have
different lists of subjects your
progress for each of
and you can download the question series
offline so if I wanted to work on Matt's
let me give me the list of topics
available I can get a hint for the
question if I wanted to so far the
company has hired 19 people all of them
studied in Ethiopia we're on our way now
to meet with the app tester an important
part of the development process we have
changes a design based on this feedback
more subjects fifteen-year-old
el-shaddai casue is in junior high
school
she's been testing the study support app
on her mobile for the past six months
it makes me to know many tanks for
example when I didn't answer some
questions I started referring books and
hurts me now shadow Castle says the app
should have a stopwatch for maths
exercises then it would make it feel
more like being in a real exam ask in de
mammal and a manual abre are soon
planning on moving their company to
Ethiopia's Silicon Valley they're
looking forward to working with other
developers there and of course to a
faster internet connection too